i gotta ask one question
and and we can cut this out if you want
is uh who's a cooler boss to work with
dana white or vince mcmahon
oh well vince is pretty [ __ ] cool but
dana's one of my best friends and like
yeah dana white's the man dude i love
dana so much like
i respected love vince mcmahon but you
know
i dana is my [ __ ] dude like
yeah dude and like
he like really like teaches me still and
inspires me a lot and he like
really is he's not just like you know
a great business partner and someone
that i have a lot of respect for
but he's like someone like near and dear
to my heart who
i there's a lot of things i disagree
with him about but
i respect his you know perspective and
he does mine and he can disagree about
things and go back and forth and
one thing that i really love about him
is we're able to
not word things right with each other
you know like
we're able to say things the wrong way
and it won't be like
what the [ __ ] you know something like
that like he could say something and
it's totally the wrong way and he
immediately
the other way and it's not going to
snowball into something else it'd be
like okay just
just tell me what you mean because um me
and
me and dana have had our days of like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you know
but um we're we're like really close
friends and it's just like
it's not like the the end or something
like that it always like
the both of us later be like oh man i'm
really sorry about that i didn't mean
that you know like
he's he really inspires me a lot in that
he like he just
doesn't let [ __ ] get to him like she
just rolls off his shoulders that
would really bother me a lot he's had a
lot of people like
betray him and you know like
the kind of things that would happen to
him would just
make me completely become callous and
close myself off and he's really stopped
me from becoming
super callous and closing myself off
when he said all
of every reason on earth to do the same
himself and
he just literally just [ __ ] just bounces
off of him
and i don't know how he does it and it's
really inspiring in a lot of ways how he
just like
is so sure of who he is
in himself that other people
not knowing that doesn't bother him at
all because he is so
sure of himself and yeah we we learn a
lot from each other
and you know like i'm not perfect he's
not perfect but i
[ __ ] love him to death and he had
faith in me when nobody else did it i
will never ever forget it
i don't know if you could say that uh
nobody had faith in you because i think
that
the the truth of the matter is that you
are so undeniable
that you have proven yourself like to
such
a stratospheric level that he just
had to bring you into the ufc so
but he didn't he didn't have to though
you know because all right
you don't have to come he already bought
out strikeforce
and they had absorbed talent and folded
every other place that they bought and
there was a very short window of time
where i was just like
they are already bringing over strike
force talent and they are about to close
this [ __ ] organization
and i have this [ __ ] window to
convince him to bring over all of the
women before folding strike force
yeah it was in hindsight it seems like
well of course
but in that short [ __ ] window of time
it was a leap of faith and completely
unproven and thank god he
likes to gamble get ready this is gonna
be gnarly
pretty gnarly
[Music]
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you gonna piss me
off